on va te faire le lentilles portrait
chinois ça c'est terrible pour des
clients comme toi c'est ce qu'il y a de
mieux
Jean-Louis Murat bonsoir bonsoir tu as
commencé par des petits boulots tu étais
quoi plagiistes non comment tu faisais
un peu tout fait quand tu étais à
Saint-Tropez et que tu voyais les mecs
du showbiz cette faisait quoi enfin tu
leur sers lui
des becquait
de servir
[Musique]
enfin maintenant que tu fais des disques
tu les trouves toujours aussi
comme tu disais bien sûr encore plus ou
moins ça sera encore plus alors tu es
monté à Paris une première fois ce qui
est très drôle d'ailleurs ton histoire
c'est il y a clairement Ferrand qui
monte à Paris tu redescends à Clermont
tu remontes à Paris alors la première
fois que tu es monté c'était c'est là où
tu as rencontré les gens derrière MC qui
t'ont un peu aîné quand même bah si ça
rentre la bande non
et puis après tu as fait un groupe tu es
redescendu d'abord tu as du tennis c'est
un peu compliqué pour moi donc tu es
redescendu et puis tu as fait un groupe
qui s'appelait Clara et puis un jour tu
as vu débarquer quand même William
Sheller Jean-Bernard rivet c'était pas
mal quand même hein c'était sympa grosse
surprise pour moi c'est ton courage
qui était
que le fan de la première heure et qui
m'est suivi
de murailles il y en a de plus en plus
qui devraient être assurés et puis alors
après tu as fait une chanson qui
s'appelait suicidez-vous le peuple est
mort c'est ça ça c'est un scandale
ben oui parce que
enfin c'est pas à sourire évidemment
mais enfin
suicidé
pour autre chose parce qu'en suicide pas
pour une chanson mais enfin ça servi de
prétexte et pour moi ça a été
une rupture un peu j'étais un peu maudit
ils ont arrêté de te passer à la radio à
tout à fait
tout arrêter Michel Abraham
et ils ont été obligé d'arrêter avec
bigoté
tous les poils tu disais c'était quoi
cette histoire
pourquoi j'étais malheureux c'était
malheureux je voulais sauter par la
fenêtre
c'était grave alors
tu te défoncer c'était suite à des
histoires de défaut
c'était un mélange
parce que surtout c'était surtout ma
propre déception qui me savais que tu
allais y arriver mais c'est arrivé pas
quand même c'est ça c'est terrible
alors là tu es nouveau avec
Clermont-Ferrand tu viens à Paris pour
la promo tel hôtel
et tu vis comment clairement
un pépère
spartiate
de bonheur
[Musique]
c'est comment d'être là-bas
ça me fait ni chenille froid en fait
j'habite clairement je pourrais habiter
ailleurs
souvent j'habite chez moi je sais pas ça
veut rien dire ça va un peu tout dire en
fait
c'est une ville qui a aucun chat ne se
charme que j'y trouve c'est que c'est
chez moi c'est une
mais tu te défonces pas rien du tout non
tu prenais de la véganine à un moment
c'était pourquoi j'en prends tout le
temps et pourquoi
je sais pas c'est devenu mon ami
il y a un quart d'heure j'en cherchais
encore ça se trouve ça non
et les effets secondaires codéine
codéine un peu
signé avec Vergine pour 6 albums
c'est tranquille là pendant 30 ans
maintenant non
pourquoi 30 ans
et encore ils peuvent te virer mais toi
tu peux pas partir non
j'en ai pas envie ça n'a pas envie avec
toi c'est tu as l'impression maintenant
que ça y est quoi tu as trouvé un autre
chez toi
tu as des projets à part d'être de
retourner paysan parce que tes
grands-parents étaient paysans
qui était élevé par mes grands-parents
tu as envie de faire ça après
de retourner encore plus loin que
Clermont-Ferrand quoi
j'ai presque envie de redevenir mon
grand-père
futur m'intéresse pas beaucoup
bizarre comme mec
écoute on va te faire l'anti portrait
chinois ça c'est terrible pour des
clients comme toi c'est ce qu'il y a de
mieux
si tu étais un défaut tu serais quoi
j'étais un défaut
tu vas être très très star
une injure
ça je sais pas incapable tu es incapable
bien sûr
si
celle de Nietzsche tu sais donner à
l'autre la honte de soi c'est la pire
chose
tu le fais deux fois quand tu servais à
Saint-Tropez
à la mousse au chocolat et puis
je comprends ça et après il me filer dis
ça que c'était encore plus rapide
c'est une infirmité
si j'étais une infirmité
pas très capable d'aimer c'est sûr
un assassin
c'est toujours avec cette fille qui
s'appelle Marie qui équilibre tu vas
rester longtemps avec elle
tu vois petit à petit tu as trouvé ton
chez toi tu as trouvé ton verdure tu as
trouvé Marie ça va s'arranger si tu
étais une arme
le double tranchant c'est sûr
de ne rien rater
[Musique]
un pouce bleu